good afternoon I am coming at you from
the Teton range in Idaho it's raining
outside today in this video I'll start
by sharing how I personally create
YouTube videos and then I'll go into
detail about the gear I use and some
tips and tricks I've learned along the
way everything I know about videography
and photography is either self-taught or
learned from other creatives my
educational background is in business
marketing and Spanish that is to say I
think it's totally possible to be
successful these days without paying
thousands of dollars for gear or
education or training so much
information is available on YouTube and
the internet for free and you can
literally just create and upload videos
with a single smartphone all that said
I've had a lot of requests over the past
year to create a video like this so here
it is I 100 still fly by the seat of my
pants when it comes to creating these
videos the finished product might look
like just a few days or even one day of
filming when in reality the cooks
usually filmed over the course of two
weeks sometimes even months I think a
lot of us end up with buckets of footage
from random moments especially with
smartphones nowadays we're like we have
a camera at our fingertips at all times
and the task of stringing them together
in a meaningful way can feel so
overwhelming that we just don't I've
found a way to make it work and I do
want to share that briefly before moving
on to what I'd actually recommend if
you're starting out fresh typically I'm
filming nature and Landscape scenes
because that's the kind of content I
love however the scenes that I do film
are kind of sporadic devoid of context
and nine times out of ten they just
don't fit well into a cohesive story
like whatsoever it's a sunset here and a
sunrise there and a random trip to the
river two weeks later and the truth is I
usually forget to film myself entirely
and it's not until I sit down with a
month or two's worth of random footage
and start piecing it together that I
realize there's absolutely no storyline
and I need to create something out of
nothing luckily my van is a constant and
reliable backdrop so I can film some
interior scenes during the editing phase
that will still flow nicely with older
footage this can work but it also makes
the editing process unnecessarily long
and super annoying I'll begin by dumping
everything into a timeline and doing my
best to arrange things in chronological
order
then I watch everything through and
usually I'm looking at three to four
hours of footage and I'll do my best to
ruthlessly cut footage down while doing
this I listen to possible music tracks
and I try to establish how the footage
is making me feel and what sort of Music
ties well into the scenery this process
can go on for days sometimes weeks
especially if I get distracted with
other work once two to three songs click
things start falling into place and I'm
able to cut the footage according to the
music establish pace and discern a clear
path forward once a project is about 80
done I begin to again reflect on how
it's all making me feel and what kind of
voice over or message might add to the
piece overall sometimes this can be the
hardest part because it's often a
marriage between this footage that was
filmed months ago and whatever I happen
to be feeling at that moment of editing
while this can all be really fulfilling
creatively when it all comes together
it is so difficult to sustain over time
I love to film so I'm always filming and
I end up with so much footage and I
don't always love to edit so there's an
imbalance and it's just not a very
effective way to sustain a YouTube
channel where still I always forget to
shoot a thumbnail I genuinely don't even
think about it until the video is 50
uploaded to YouTube and you know a bunch
of those generic thumbnail options are
generated and I'm like crap ninety
percent of the time I scrub through the
finished video looking for some
screenshot that I can extract and
hopefully edit well enough to satisfy
the algorithm Gods I would encourage you
to do the opposite and actually
prioritize shooting your thumbnail it's
annoying but title and thumbnail are a
huge factor in whether or not people
actually click on your content and watch
your video a strategy I found to work
infinitely better are pre-planned
concepts with rough outlines and shot
lists that can be executed in the same
location preferably on the same day I've
personally done this successfully a few
different times and the editing only
took me two days as opposed to literal
weeks of creative gymnastics this sort
of approach it requires commitment and
planning both of which can be somewhat
of a challenge when living full-time on
the road not impossible but challenging
living on the road is a full-time job at
creating weekly YouTube videos to the
mix and running a business and there
goes your personal life if I can offer
any advice from what I've learned it's
to film with intention after assembling
a rough outline and loose list of what
you'd like to create but also sprinkle
in some of that make what you want when
you want energy because I really do
think that's one of the secret sauces
says that's one of the secret sauce that
keeps the creativity going when I'm
creating an outline I like to First
think about what kind of story I want to
tell and for me that usually hinges on
how place makes me feel this video about
Yosemite for example the weather was so
stormy and Moody and it felt
otherworldly to me and the story that
emerged had this dreamlike theme where I
reflected on Past Times from that same
location weather does often impact the
work I create both literally and
figuratively the same way it affects my
day-to-day life once you have a loose
idea of your theme you can build scenes
to support the story I try to keep in
mind three types of shots whenever
building a scene establishing
environmental and immersive and
establishing shots AKA The Long Shot
serves as an introduction to the story
that's about to unfold an environmental
shot is somewhat closer than the
establishing shot so viewers can more
closely explore the scenery here for
example I show a mixture of establishing
environmental shots to give the viewer a
clear idea of the surrounding Landscapes
and how my van and I are existing in
this environment these sort of shots are
where I typically get my workout in
running back and forth to set up and
retrieve my camera in between takes
especially as a solo Creator these kind
of scenes can require a little extra
effort and risk especially if you're
like me and leave your camera tendon to
get drive-by shots but they are still
possible with some creativity this cut
to me cooking is what I would consider
an immersion shot it brings the viewer
directly into my space and shows a
zoomed in perspective of how I'm
interacting with that space within the
surrounding environment from this short
sequence the viewer can deduce that I'm
parked in the desert with my van it's
morning and I'm making breakfast
cool so now what like why would anyone
want to watch that that's the real
challenge in creating videos worth
watching what kind of value are you
bringing to your viewer or is your
primary focus to create a visual Journal
of sorts for just yourself and your
family and you could really care less if
anyone watches it deciding which Camp
you fall into can help you determine how
much effort you want to put into the
development of a storyline in your
videos and by that I mean does your
video have a beginning middle and end
are there clear locations characters and
events what sort of Journey are you
taking me on is there some kind of
obstacle or challenge that you introduce
where there's a resolution or desired
end these are questions I don't always
ask or answer myself in my own videos
but I do look for them when consuming
content I want to touch briefly on the
visual aspect this is like my third time
recording this because oh my gosh the
light just changed again it's maddening
it's no longer raining but clouds are
passing overhead and so it's like dark
flight dark I film about 90 of my
footage during two times of the day
sunrise and sunset that's when you'll
get the most dynamic flattering light
and it can take an ordinary scene and
turn it into something really beautiful
and artistic editing can also play a
huge part in terms of amplifying color
and improving composition I personally
use Adobe Premiere Pro for all my video
editing though I'm likely going to
transition over to DaVinci Resolve just
as soon as I find the time this is one
area where I do believe a financial
investment in a workshop or course to
thoroughly learn your editing software
is a really good move I spent years
watching random Youtube videos about
Premiere Pro and learning small tidbits
here and there and then last year I took
a workshop by Sam colder on Premiere Pro
and I literally learned more in three
years than I had in seven I could have
saved myself so much time and
frustration if I had just done that from
the very beginning another element
that's really important is good audio
I'm still very much learning in this
department it but I have cycled through
a handful of microphones and I've landed
on two that work really well for me and
we'll go over those shortly and finally
camera gear having the right gear can
make a big difference when it comes to
the visual aspects of your work for
example here's a shot taken with my
iPhone of a scene and here's a shot from
that same scene taken with my camera and
long lens but be warned this is where
things can also get very expensive so
before I dive into the gear I use just
remember that story is King if you have
a compelling story and decent audio the
visuals can be a total afterthought and
people will still want to engage
podcasts are a great example of that
visuals are only a piece of the puzzle
so I just encourage you to avoid getting
caught up in the idea that you need the
latest greatest and Best Equipment to
create if you have a smartphone and a
few creative ideas you genuinely have
what you need to get started with
creating your own YouTube videos all of
that said let's nerd out but first let's
send it over to editing Christian fort
today's sponsor musicbed
hi long time no see so you're a creative
person with great ideas and you want to
make videos that stand out music bed can
help you with that with a curated roster
of over 40 000 artists that you won't
find anywhere else musicbed can help you
grow as a creator with songs that both
strengthen and support your skills as a
Storyteller I personally discovered my
current editing style when I found some
of my favorite songs were available as
instrumental versions and I was able to
fuse music visuals and the spoken word
in a way that worked really well and has
helped me develop into the Creator I am
today take your projects and films to
the next level with musicbed hear the
difference yourself when you sign up for
a free account and use code C Schaefer
at checkout to receive one month free
when you purchase an annual subscription
thanks again to musicbed for sponsoring
this video links to everything I share
here can be found on my website and I'll
also include this link in the caption
below I do earn a small affiliate
Commission on some of these items which
means if you order using the links on my
website you can support my channel
Channel at no additional cost to you
this is my primary camera the Canon EOS
R5 mirrorless camera body I love the R5
for both photography and videography it
has a 45 megapixel sensor records 120
frames per second in 4k records up to 8K
it has face tracking and in body image
stabilization plus it's rugged and it
has a flip out screen that makes filming
myself a little bit easier would I
recommend this camera for vlogging no
not really with a lens mounted it's
pretty heavy and there are better
cameras out there if your primary goal
is a lightweight vlogging setup but if
you're looking to film cinematic scenes
and have a camera that is professional
grade for both photography and
videography without investing in a
cinema camera I do think this is a solid
option my current collection is Canon L
Series glass I've gone through so many
phases with lenses I started with a kit
lens then slowly built a collection of
Sigma Tamron Rokinon and the Canon EF
lens line and over time time I've
transitioned to Canon exclusively and
primarily the RF line I've never dabbled
into Sony or Nikon or any of the other
major brands I have heard really good
things but I just love Canon for its
durability it's natural color tones and
the quality of glass this is my favorite
lens the Canon RF 100 to 500 F 4.5 so
7.1 this lens allows me to punch in on
details especially Mountain layers and
distant Vistas with this one lens I can
capture 10 to 12 unique compositions
from a single Sunset whereas say the 15
to 35 can only capture like two to three
because it's such a wide angle lens
another advantage of the 100 to 500 is
that I'm able to shoot beautiful
cinematic scenes from the comfort of my
van because it's such a telephoto lens
it can punch way off into the distance
and that's really helpful if it's windy
or rainy outside it's great for
compression punching in and somewhat
useful when capturing Wildlife a 2.8
lens would definitely be better but it
would also be massive and not very
practical for the van this is my
Workhorse lens if I was going to go on a
trip and could only take one lens with
me this would be it this is the Canon 24
to 70 F 2.8 it's wide enough at the 24
end to capture Interiors like the van
and punched in Far Enough at the 70 end
that it can capture 90 or situations
well enough when I have just one shot at
capturing something and I need the focus
and composition to be spot on this is
the lens I would turn to the Canon rf15
to 35 F 2.8 this is a really wide angle
lens and it's perfect for shooting
inside the van and other small spaces
for example a tent shot or driving scene
up on the windshield I'll often set up
my tripod and just point this right out
the windshield and then I can crop in or
zoom in it's also useful for capturing a
sweeping landscape like say an overhead
Arch or a Mountain View with flowers in
the foreground because of the lower
aperture you can even use this lens for
capturing night skies and the Milky Way
the Canon rf85 1.2 and the Canon ef35
1.4 with prime lenses you're a bit more
limited when it comes to composition the
only way to reframe an image is to
physically create distance between
yourself and your subject I find that
having that kind of restraint actually
encourages me to get more creative when
shooting the great thing about prime
lenses is the wider aperture and the
shallower depth of field which allows
you to really zero in on your subject
and blur out any distracting backgrounds
or surroundings this is also how you
achieve What's called the bokeh effect
and since the aperture is wider more
light can be let in which makes these
lenses ideal for shooting at Blue hour
or even nighttime and campfire scenes
One Challenge I'm still trying to
navigate with these is how to get proper
focus on myself since I shoot alone
especially with this 85 because the
setup is usually at a distance and I
can't see what the camera seeing or what
it's focusing on oftentimes just off by
the tiniest amount but it's weird
because it's like focusing on my
shoulder instead of my face and I do
have face tracking on the Canon R5 but
it just doesn't always nail it I have
heard their apps for that so I might
have to look into those I will say
though that the footage it does take and
is in Focus I absolutely love like it's
so beautiful it's technically a portrait
lens and I shoot mostly Landscapes it's
been interesting trying to figure out
creative ways to use it and incorporate
it into my work this 35 is actually an
EF prime lens which is the predecessor
of the Canon RF line and so it requires
a Canon mount adapter in order for it to
fit on my R5 and I'll just show you guys
real quick with this Mount I can attach
any EF lens onto my Canon R5 I also want
to mention another favorite which is the
Canon RF 700 to 200 2.8 I've had the EF
version of this lens for the longest
time I just don't have the space for two
telephoto lenses I had to kind of choose
just one and it went with 100 to 500 but
the 70 to 200 is an amazing lens and
there's been so many times that I regret
selling mine okay audio
[Music]
I have been through a handful of
microphones and these are the two that I
use the most the rode videomic ntg on
camera shotgun microphone with the rode
windshield and the rode Wireless go to
dual Channel wireless microphone system
I'm not going to go into details on
either of these because I really only
have a basic understanding but based on
my research and personal use these are
really solid bets in the audio
department I have a collection of
circular polarizers light diffusers UV
filters these are both variable ND
filters I use them constantly since I'm
typically filming with a shutter speed
of 1 over 50 and I exported 24 frames
per second so these are part of the
Peter McKinnon signature edition line I
absolutely love them this one is a two
to five stop and this is a six to nine
stop and this typically lives on my 85
millimeter Prime since the aperture is
so wide at F 1.2 essentially what that
means is the 1.2 aperture allows in so
much light that a filter like this is
needed to block the light you can see
how dark this is it's just like
practically ink black my one and only
trusted tripod for my Canon R5 it's the
peak design carbon fiber travel tripod
this thing has been through a lot and
it's still going strong I love the fluid
ball head and quick release plate it's
lightweight sturdy and expensive worth
every penny if you ask me I also have an
assortment of smaller tripods and iPhone
attachments I just have these stashed
everywhere if I'm using my main camera
to film that I can throw one of these up
and get a different angle I've never
actually had a selfie stick before
and I kind of like it I mean you can
really get high up there with minimal
effort and it weighs next to nothing and
the Joby is really helpful because you
can put it in all kinds of weird
precarious situations and like have it
grab onto a tree branch or something
like that so these are really handy to
have this is the camera that I use 30 of
the time sometimes more it shoots 4K it
shoots slo-mo has cinematic versions
they're just so Advanced these days it's
incredible what this can do also the
exposure is kind of effortless it
doesn't require a lot of post editing
which I it just makes my life so much
easier and it's just always with me fits
in my back pocket and it's really
convenient I personally have a number of
iPhones because I find them to be really
useful when I'm shooting different
angles or if I'm driving and I have one
you know propped up on the windshield I
can have the other one with Google Maps
and music playing if I want to pop my
drone up in the air I can go ahead and
fly with one phone and also have the
other one it's also just good as a solo
female traveler being you know full-time
on the road it's nice to have a backup
in case my bag gets stolen or I drop my
phone while hiking in the mountains a
lot of the times I'm camping out in the
middle of nowhere there's not an Apple
Store nearby I wouldn't want to have to
like change my entire itinerary and
whatnot just to get a phone so I keep my
older phones and they come in really
handy I have like four or five different
battery packs on hand at all times
because I use my phone for filming music
calendar voice calls text messaging
social media having these backups handy
and fully charged is really essential
this is the camera bag that I currently
use it's an osprey day pack the series
24. I just throw a camera cube with
whatever lenses I want to take in this
main compartment and then all of my
camera accessories up top I've cycled
through about eight or nine different
specialized camera bags and ultimately I
found a regular backpacking bag to just
be the most practical cool and
comfortable for the kind of work I do
since it usually involves a fair amount
of hiking and heavier gear this is
called the peak design capture camera
clip it basically lives on my day pack
and I'm able to attach my camera and
lens to it like so I hiked the entire
John Muir Trail which is 242 miles with
my camera dangling off of one of these
and not once did it slip or fall so I
trust it through and through this is a
peak design camera strap and I have two
of these since I usually have a backup
camera although right now I don't I'm
waiting for the new R5 version 2 to
release I use a lot of peak design gear
and what I love about it is the seamless
system of anchors and quick release
plates I can easily attach or detach the
camera strap transition over to my
tripod or clip into my backpack with
little to no effort which is really
helpful in most shooting situations
especially when backpacking or when
dealing with quickly changing conditions
this is the DJI mavic 2 Pro I was in the
habit for a while buying the newest
drone and because it always felt so new
and like high stakes when I was flying
it I didn't take many risks and I didn't
fly it as often and now that I have an
older version I find that I use it a lot
more when I do upgrade I'll probably go
with the DJI mavic 3 Pro the DJI osmo
action I use this sometimes for Creative
angles inside the van it's waterproof I
think it's shock proof because I've
dropped it so many times and it still
works really well I have these mounts
throughout the van where I can easily
just throw this camera up to be
perfectly honest it is an opt-in that I
actually use this footage because the
quality is just so different from the R5
it does come in handy for like Quick
Cuts or weird moments caught on camera
okay guys speed round because this video
is getting way too long I do briefly
want to go over my editing gear and that
includes this apple 16 inch MacBook Pro
it is the M1 Max 2 terabyte these Apple
air pods I take hiking with me I take on
planes I am using them constantly
especially being in the van sometimes
there's a lot of loud ambient exterior
noise this is the Apple iPad Pro 12.9
inch 6th gen 1 terabyte with the magic
keyboard is that upside down there you
go most often I'm using this as a second
display for my laptop when I'm doing
video editing
um I'll put the source bin up on here
just so that I can have more real estate
and I'm not like squinting and hunched
over my laptop this is my wireless Apple
keyboard this helps with my posture so
that I can have my laptop up high and
still have my elbows at a 90 degree
angle also this is probably my favorite
accessory this is a laptop stand it's
boyada I just got this from Amazon
having this just helps prevent any kind
of injuries like carpal tunnel or being
hunched over my laptop all the time very
essential for my workflow also the
Logitech MX anywhere 3 compact wireless
mouse if you've followed me for a long
time you remember like two years ago I
did an ad for this I've dropped this
thing so many times and I literally it
it has never failed me I will not travel
anywhere without this if anything were
to happen to it I would just I would buy
it again and again and again this is the
sandusk professional Pro card reader for
CF Express I bought a cheaper one off of
Amazon and one day it started smoking I
don't mess around anymore I highly
recommend this one these are all my
camera cards I use the CF Express cards
most since I shoot 4K video this is my
tech pouch where I store a lot of my
cords and hard drives I use on a daily
basis this is one of the pouches that
you saw on the back of the drawer where
I just keep all of my cords organized
and a fellow photographer one of you
recently sent me this shout out to Nick
for gifting me this practically Mint
Condition Canon film camera I'm really
excited to learn be on the lookout for
some future film coming at you I don't
know anything about this camera yet
I took my first photo it was of my
tripod cool
hard drives this is a system that I'm
constantly revising especially now that
I'm shooting everything in 4k sometimes
a single video can have one terabyte
worth of footage which means I am
constantly culling and deleting footage
just to keep the essentials only which
really sucks but it's just kind of like
reality of living on the road I don't
think uploading everything to the cloud
would be practical given how much
internet and time that would require
because I'm constantly shooting and I
really like having all my files
accessible when I travel without having
to download them from the cloud so I
have managed to keep my entire video
archive limited to eight terabytes which
is stored on these two four terabyte
solid state drives and then I have two
additional copies of these drives on
solid state as backup this is my master
drive for photography I have managed to
keep it under five terabytes my entire
photography archive I have three
redundant backups of this three time
machine backups and an SSD working drive
for current client projects and an
additional backup of everything in my
storage unit this is honestly one of the
main reasons I think about having a home
base is because I dream of having a raid
Tower where I can back everything up and
just never have to delete footage again
one day so that's most of my camera and
editing gear I tried to run through it
quickly without getting into too much
detail just for the sake of time I don't
consider myself a tech junkie whatsoever
but I do have a fair amount of
experience using everything I mentioned
here and I've personally always looked
up to other creatives just to see what
they're using as a way of improving my
own setup so I really hope some of you
found this helpful if you want to learn
more about the technical specs of
anything I mentioned here just be sure
to check out the product links on my
website thank you for being here love
you guys ciao
welcome back I feel like this is the
longest video of all time
chaos pure chaos I need a nap I am ready
to film
what was I gonna say I'm gonna go get
coffee
[Music]
foreign